hey guys what's up this is andrew from
trendsenses.com
so let me quickly introduce myself for
those who are watching my video for the
first time
i've been working as a professional
trader for the past six years in hong
kong
and right now i do youtube videos guys
and i'm here to pass the knowledge to
show you
everything that i learned at work mostly
by myself
and i'm actually only showing you guys
what is working for me
what i use to make money on the markets
so in this video i want to make a
huge update guys on gamestop let's get
into it
[Music]
alright guys so let's sum up a bit the
situation
here we had a strong strong day
yesterday
so on tuesday the market took 12 and
then after hours it's
up two more percent so let me remind you
the different scenarios that i had here
for you guys
all right i was actually analyzing this
first wave guys
this is only a first wave let me remind
you this
all right we just broke here this
trend line in red that to me was the
trendline we needed to
trade above so that we could we can
start our five wave development to 800
or
more uh we need to know where this first
wave is going to bring us first
and then once we know the size of the
first wave is going to be very
interesting
it's going to be very useful sorry to
actually
predict the size of the coming waves as
well and maybe the end of this
five wave development so here before
maybe we're gonna have
uh one more five wave development all
right so this can
never stop of course but i do this
step by step guys you know i analyze the
data i have
and using this data i'm trying to give
you some
signals some projections some
predictions that you can use to set up
your trades
so here my scenario was that this first
wave
that is actually you know this one here
for now it's not complete guys you know
i told you that there was 90
chance in my last video that we bounced
back at the 220 level
and that we actually you know trade
higher
on tuesday session which we actually did
and
it doesn't mean that we're not gonna
correct this is just
this was expected i can see that the
whole day we were trading higher so this
is very good i like those bullish days
you know when the market
is not uh correcting during the day when
the market is just going one way up
and is even in after hours going even
higher this is a very bullish signal
just by itself so here let me do some
counting with you so i showed you one
two three four five abc
one two three four five abc and right
now we're looking
for this fifth wave guys so the fifth
wave usually when the third wave
is very you know strong and extended
like it is the case here usually fifth
waves
they are actually you know smaller than
the third wave
so i think that the fifth wave might go
to the 300 level
it's also possible that the fixed wave
goes to the 380 level right away
why 380 because it's the maximum i had
here guys you know
during this rally in gen 21 yes we had
some consolidation
around the 380 level so it's a level the
market still has in mind
so here either we go in this uh scenario
to 300 or we go to 380 and we would go
there very quickly
let me show you guys a good technique
that you can use
to actually ride the wave you know all
the way up
without actually taking a lot of risk is
you just need to find some moving
average that
support the price action in the wave
development
so for those who have watched my video
on amc i use the same technique
for amc i go on the hourly time frame i
use the 20 period moving average
for gamestop you can see that the 20
period moving average is not
strong enough you know because the price
action actually is not strong enough so
the 20 period moving average is not
supporting the price but the 50 period
moving average
let me change the color
okay so the one here
in purple you can see guys that it's
supporting perfectly the price guys
uh the whole way up so here we have one
reaction
two reactions three reactions all right
and those reactions are perfect
so this moving average is actually the
one that you need to follow
if we are trading above this moving
average it means we are bullish
it means we gonna develop higher and if
suddenly we trade below it so let's
imagine you know
doing something like this and the price
action is doing something like this and
suddenly here you can see we go
we break it we retest it then we would
probably correct
so you need to follow this kind of
signal to know
before it happens or at very you know
good levels
when the market is actually gonna
correct so
here let me make some more scenarios
with you and let me
tell you what is my preferred one so
here my preferred scenario is this one
all right
i showed you guys this so in my last
video i told you i don't know
here if we're gonna do maybe a zigzag
maybe even correct here a bit lower
i was awaiting more data to um
kind of select my scenario and right now
i have a very strong bullish day
strong after hours so my preferred
scenario is
still the same one this was my preferred
scenario but the other ones are almost
eliminated
all right so i think we're gonna do a
first wave that goes up to
300 so this is my
preferred scenario so let me put it this
way guys all right so we go here
we go to 300 then we're gonna correct
and that's why
elliot wave is actually very important
guys and it's
a tool that is helping you a lot in your
training
is that if we actually do have this wave
development
like this the yellow one that i think is
happening
right now then you know that the second
wave
once we start correcting the second wave
of
this purple five-way development here is
gonna correct
either to the top of the third wave so
it's would be very bullish only here
or to the bottom of the force wave so
then we would come back to 220
and if we do so then we would come back
to 220.
so it's a level that we probably gonna
see again
if some of you are wondering should i
buy gamestop shares right now
if you didn't buy you know when we had
the breakout
here or you know during this whole
strong impulse that we had when i was
actually telling you guys that this
looks good that this is bullish if you
haven't bought your shares
here you usually we like to retest those
major levels so we might still have a
retest of this
level but now this level starts to be
very far away
so it might be one of the rare situation
where we don't retest this level
but we probably gonna retest the 220
level
so we have two scenarios either we go
here and then we correct 220
and then we go higher or that is still
on the table guys
we could still have something like this
is that actually this
one two three four five is like this
this is a scenario that we need to keep
in mind guys because it's still on the
table
this is a valid counting as well once
again the third wave here is very strong
a small
fifth wave can happen and then here we
would have an abc
like this you know flat here zigzag here
we're gonna have a flat
okay so then this first wave is complete
and
if this is the case if this first wave
is complete we could have a flat
but we could also go here and then do
one two three four five
so okay so this is a scenario that can
happen as well
doing a flat or coming back even here
i don't think we actually gonna come
back now to this level because the b
wave is actually very high
so we are close to a flat correction you
can check this flat corrections need to
go
above the open 786 level of fib
so right now we didn't reach it all
right so it can still be a zigzag
if we tread above 260 the zigzag is off
the table
so then we know that if the zigzag is up
the table that 220
would probably hold right now we're not
sure 220 can break
and we can still go here but once again
guys this is really not my perfect
scenario because i
see a very strong here bullish momentum
on
amc as well so i think that we're gonna
complete this
first wave higher than correct only here
so this is
up
here we go
okay revealed so this
is my preferred tsunami guys so this is
what i think is gonna happen so let's
see if i'm correct or not
you know idiot with counting can be very
tricky because as you can see guys
you know you never know if a wave is
developed or not
when a wave is developed it it means
that actually for example the fifth wave
is going to contain five waves
or the first wave is going to contain
five waves here i did my first wave in
five waves
here i did my first wave but it's a
lower degree wave counting but
you know you you never know if it's
developed or not so it's actually very
hard
to find the right counting before it
happens so that's why you need to
associate
this technique of idiot wave counting
with other techniques
that for example are moving averages
here i'm associating this with moving
averages and trend lines
you know 220 is a trend line 220 is also
a support given by the 50 period moving
average
so you need to associate illegal wave
theory
with moving averages trend lines
fibonacci
and the signals given by the market when
a day
is up the whole day is up it means there
are no sellers
only buyers and aftermarket is still
bullish
guys this is bullish so when i associate
all of this
together it gives me a first wave
that goes to 300. once again this is a
very precise scenario
let's see if this is correct maybe not
if not i'm gonna adapt but still
the one that you know gonna happen
i think you know with a very high
probability
even if the odds look very low
but you know to me it's the one where we
go to 800.
you know this scenario is to me kind of
obvious so i don't know
i don't know we're gonna follow this
we're gonna follow this closely
and we're gonna see if yes or not this
is happening one more thing
guys let's see the option market guys
because this is actually what pushed amc
price to this very high levels all right
so let me make an update
so we had only six percent guys of short
interest on gamestop
you know an amc we're having 17 18
right now on the total of 23 so guys
market makers
got here hammered you know they it was
very tough for them we went through all
the strikes
on imc stock so here we are six percent
but gamestop is
slightly higher game stuff is at 250
right now
so we are at seven percent seven percent
on the total of seventeen percent
so we have some gamma guys we have those
800 strikes
that are full of gamma and that can
create the same
bullish momentum we had on amc very
quickly the short interest
20 here if i had the synthetic short
it's a total of 27 so it's not a lot
guys that's why
the most is not gonna happen right now
the most is gonna happen probably after
the correction of the third wave
okay if we go to 800 then hedge funds
are going to load
some heavy short positions and then they
can get squeezed
for now this is just you know a gamma
squeeze which is
softer and amc just to remind you is
that 39
so this is getting hot what else
volatility guys 225
for the 800 strike so this is growing
guys this is a lot
all right so this is the july maturity
it was at
170 you know not that long ago so it's
growing it's good
it it's a it's an indicator i like to
follow guys
and of course i followed the total
number of shots here
right now we had 3 million shares we
were you know around 2 million not that
long ago so this is growing as well guys
so everything looks very good to me on
this
stock so that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub
like and bell button so you're going to
be the first to know when i upload
anything
new and stay close to shore i see you
guys